[Music]  I grew up in Boyle Heights I remember  when I was a kid pops always said one  day we don't build a car together low  lighters are my family I said coming up  a story about this kid from East LA  who's a graffiti artist Danny just wants  to express his art action he is very  very talented but he's not choosing the  right path I guarantee I'm gonna make it  with my art ghostess Danny's older  brother who went to jail man he comes  back in their lives there's a lot of  emotions that get stirred up you know  people call me now ghosts cuz for the  last eight years you haven't so much as  mention my name  Danny's fine he's held in the middle  between his father and his brother screw  old school what he's up against needs to  choose which world is gonna be part of  that is your heritage something you know  nothing about  about love art and family  [Music]  you